so this is more of a continued
conversation that we have no no no no
it's more of a continued conversation we
have a small group here we can continue
the conversation that we are having we
have the recording to share with the
rest of the group because I think that
there's more interest in this topic than
we have time for and of course you
better than running to other sessions
that they would like to see so we help
continue the conversation now and then
other people can check in later I think
we will keep it to 30 minutes so that we
can give a video team a break and then
also so that we can get you to your next
talk because Rafa is giving the talk on
creative AI later today so I will then
let you take it away in terms of so some
of the other keynote conversations have
been more just yeah slightly less formal
than when were on stage said maybe we
can have more of a chat yes so so maybe
we should just start since we write so
many we should maybe just let's have an
introduction of everyone here if you
don't mind if you don't mind we can have
this a nice a nice informal chat I'm
gerak I work as a business analyst
that's basically it I mean I use machine
learning the hardly ever but to
statistical analysis a lot I'm I'm
Christian I'm a Python trainer located
in Berlin and I do translations for
O'Reilly I am Olga and chief operating
officer good AI sir Alex colleague
we could use that microphone as well for
Anna hi I'm Anna quite a brief
introduction Anna um and I work with
data since 30 years or so and boring I
got more and more into this ethics thing
is also from a UI perspective in German
we call this house after listen this is
how I started to tackle computers at all
that now this magic sauce AI scares me
off mostly because I know how stupid
computers are and I just did those
earlier we need a codec this has been
told since years where is it so and I
totally agree as developers I write code
we are on the front line to reality and
if there are no codecs because law is
behind which I also doubt maybe we just
don't know about law yeah if we say oh
my program so there's no law runs my
program there are some things that do we
know enough about law to say that this
is legal what we're doing other things
this isn't him clear because it wasn't a
tackle so I want to meet law yes about
that yes I'm really interested in this
topic and I like also to see broad
abroad
most of us develop I also want to take
action for band break I was organizing
last year's PI data where we had Julia
Evans here who just broke Google's image
recognition model Queen Elizabeth says
shower carpet and so sweet to show
people oh no don't be that scared
it's
I should keep critical-thinking up me
may I reply something because actually I
bought a broader book here which buzz by
EULA fights in bomb called crews often
iceberg and it's basically this book
from the 80s lights in long being an MIT
professor and the inventor of Eliza and
he's making exact same point that we
make made today and it's all these like
the same issues and they had them he was
actually much more concerned about the
military in the book we didn't like when
he touched upon it which i think is
interesting but yeah I mean the history
repeats itself but it's also that AI
hype is really at a peak or maybe beyond
the peak but really high at this moment
so the thing is good to at least talk
about it again
think about it again I mean I I agree I
think that law is a very bad thing too
if I totally agree having worked in many
different startups law is something we
tend not to really worry about until you
know these companies get up to a certain
size as you can see with Wilbur we
really doesn't get the [ __ ] up tool
until they are these kind of mega
billion and then they start to care
about loss or actually no not still are
already times too big to fail and start
playing around with them so that's the
two options as I see them and sometimes
you do work with LA but then you're one
of the few so it really works against
you on the kind of general current
economical system like competitive
economical system we have so why would
you be the kind of good student
among the many if there's no rule
incentive there except maybe a little
bit of PR damage but you know that can
be well maintained and I think the other
thing is interesting like yes we were
think we're talking about code of
conduct or things which there was one
which mentioned 25 years ago but
actually was never used so it's
interesting
suppose there was our excellent kind of
code of contact for for data
practitioners starting AI but it's more
kind of the yes we inherently believe in
this together but what that right what
do you do after that after you agree
that this is kind of wanted behavior or
things you don't want to do like what
else they're like how do you make sure
that these things are actually holding
up so
to start thinking maybe practically
since it seems that this eye data is
very ethical ethics oriented merica
think about like how could we bring life
to such an initiative if it's like in
Germany we have the strong culture of
unions right and we have this history of
people getting together and discussing
things and another I mean us now coming
together and it's weekend and we're
still discussing ethics on the Sunday
it's very nice and it's a good sign and
people do care and it's really
interesting also that there's so little
shame right that basically a company
like uber wouldn't would not not do
things because of shame but only if they
have to pay billions right I don't know
if it's ever been better or different
but it's just something to consider I
mean and I think that this is part of
the problem and um I've been doing some
research I have an upcoming talk about
sort of the historical epochs around
computing and some of the research that
I've been doing is these things that
I've never heard of that I've people
that have never read about and they are
not the superstars that they were asking
some of these questions even some of the
superstars the types of concerns and
skepticism they had later in their
career really turning on the idea of AI
and really changing their perspective on
the entire thing and what we should be
allowed to build and not allowed to
build and I think that a lot of times we
don't have this communal cultural
understanding of this history and these
issues we instead approach it every day
like a new problem and I think that
because culture and history informs our
own personal moral philosophy that why
would it not also then culturally inform
ourselves as a group as either a
computer scientists or data scientists
like that this understanding of you know
the evolution of our philosophy around
these things that we are very
short-sighted or or tend to be somewhat
short-sighted and it's not often in
school that you're forced to kind of
learn some of this history even if you
study for quite a long time in some of
these fields
yeah I was because I said so much
history is it it's because the other
thing is always also new and it's a
revolution we're going to we're not this
is quite boring this is all [ __ ] so
what do we learn from this if we all
believe it
storytelling as big as well so we should
start to tell stories about this to get
bigger I just downloaded the dictionary
modern dictionary of the history of
ideas started with information and this
information overflow just too much it
was the 1803 I was discussing the same
so looking back finding stories could be
an approach making it playful I loved
voice you eyes cuz for the first time
ever in my life I see normal human
beings recognizing how stupid computers
are normally they say I'm too stupid for
this you do need your son this is a
chance I wanted Alexa talks to Google
home talks to GE as there's so many
things to show how stupid this stuff is
there could be even fun right why why
not I'd really like to collect but
especially history in the past right
Saddam as you most there are laws for
robots right but I'm also curious
Merrick on your work because you're
trying to build like more of this like
general AI and a lot of these like
historians like this was their goal this
is their dream is once I have these like
general AI to help me make good
decisions really curious kind of like
why you started your company and kind of
like what inspired you to kind of work
on these things that I feel like a lot
of other practitioners of AI have just
given up on and is open I do computer
assisted driving you know or something
the reason is
I still believe think my child with that
intelligence is a way how to like
optimize many of things and if you want
to optimize more things we need to
alternate intelligence and another way
on how to remember is that I see
intelligence as the best leverage that
we can have you know like either I can
solve like space rocket electrically
computer games blah blah blah or I can
build a it--and of salt all these things
so it's probably the most conscious
things from all these but if we get
successful with automating the
intelligence all the other things will
be unlocked basically like
instantaneously and so this is a dozen
degrees in bed I think that we people
are the limit with our intelligence and
I mean we are still the most intelligent
another you know like agent varies
around here but but according to the
brain we cannot really there are some
only few ways how we can improve our our
intelligence basically one of them is to
learning or learn how to learn but we
cannot change our hardware can change
change our software we cannot clone you
know we cannot do all these things and
also a human
as certain value which repeat us from
doing certain things for example will
never build a like one time spaceship
you know with people like descending
they're even Carol they're considered to
the astronomical event but with a I
usually like if you're just machining
and this can actually it is a course of
a lot of exploration things or I'll both
side maybe will be much cheaper you know
when can ultimate the intelligent so
again I'll whenever almost could I be
doing currently
I still see AI or AGI as the first thing
I think it's definitely interesting
because just I've been sending a lot of
time reading a lot of these historical
books from the 50s and 60s in their
dreams and being able to have you know
conversation with it AI and have it has
you know an understanding of empathy and
all these types of things and then it
seems like a lot of this conversation is
almost completely gone from the
conversation today it's about optimizing
accuracy and how exactly perfect can I
get for this specific task maybe I could
actually our approaches may be slightly
differently goes the AI we want to build
is AI the reason we don't even know what
tasks the AI will be solving it you know
this is of like the domain of where our
IP will be operating with how to improve
itself or how to improve its
adaptability so that it's able to solve
any task that may come in so today most
people meant
they are working talking about AI that
can solve very specific tasks like
people know exactly what you'll be doing
but what we want to do is AI that we
don't even know the AI will be solving
and what kind of architecture the AI
will need in order to solve a lot of
problems of basically a lot of our work
in metal ring and musical gradual
learning so is about the AI improving
itself and improving its ability to
adapt to new normal unseen tasks and so
and then of course the questions a lot
of kind of tasks we all we need from the
ALU source and how what values to Egypt
select bias in the positive way is also
ectopic for us so actually I will not
even talk about my understanding of what
we want to build is not about some
function organization supplement because
I don't even know what we function what
it may be I just I would say that the
function is actually like a brute
adaptability of the AI that's something
every three so it's like
maximizing the future options of tasks
that the AI cancel you I don't know what
the task and I would like to add that
the conversation is still ongoing with
the it's just in a different room maybe
in others in the science technology
studies I think people are very
concerned with these kind of issues as a
wonderful book by Lucy Suchman
especially on this voice was a systems
and there's also for instance Adrian
McKenzie in Lancaster on the writing on
the performativity of prediction and
what it all means but what I'd also be
really interested in because now is like
kinda like have to almost like an
academic discourse again what do the
people actually talk to clients actually
talk to the companies what they think
and what they make out of this Prince's
million reias can can pitch in but also
the the people you who actually train
large company I don't know who you train
of course but what's your perspective is
too naive does this actually make sense
or I was stating the obvious
so I mean most companies I work with
they don't think about like general AI
they mostly don't think about normally I
either because they were already
struggling even getting the data in a
shape where they can actually use it at
least most companies here in Germany
that are not like very close to like the
software model you know in the u.s. you
have a course like very big companies
that are very good at doing these kind
of things but here I think the
discussion is not can we have like some
general I I as I solve stuff but how can
we even like get our data in a form that
we can work with that and do that in a
way that's secure and so that we don't
lose everything yeah so I think I'm not
very qualified to answer like what would
be general direction in which we should
go for that because like the problems
that I'm trying to solve a much simpler
in that sense I can agree on that
because the the people at that I talk to
usually they have some very clear
business function that they want to
optimize like if you talk to a phone
company they want to I don't know
optimize revenues from from mobile
mobile phone calls on and if you talk to
a some membership based service and you
want people to stay members for as long
as possible and each of these is fine in
itself but what we are trying to look
here is the the bigger picture when you
are have one company that tries to to
maximize its own profit this is no
problem in itself but if everybody in
the society does this end it in my
opinion it becomes unethical and since
we are dealing with the the data around
all these bigger issues then we
necessarily have to view the view it
from a wider angle as well
yeah I'm I want to throw a bit of a
different point but maybe it's I mean
it's all interlinked we've been talking
or we are talking about ethics and
machine learning and open data of course
and so far to me it seems like we've
been talking a lot about what should be
allowed how do we improve our
intelligence how do we make our
algorithms fair by not discriminating
against anybody and so on and while all
this is important of course I think so
far the question hasn't been reflected
what happens with with my work when I
publish a new thing like with every step
with every contribution towards it more
more more able a I also contribute to
what have you workers being replaced by
robots or autonomous armed drones
shooting people and what what is their
responsibility I as a contributor to all
packages and AI actually have like
thinking of when when Einstein
researched he didn't didn't think of
building a nuclear bomb but actually he
did in the end so what I've been
wondering all the conversation along is
what there are the responsibilities of
each single person contributing to the
whole open-source and AI world I think
that's that's a good question and so
let's go into that after the so I can
say something about so the clients I
deal with them to be big and device type
companies and stuff so when we talk to
them they're they're generally or
they're very much on the kind of end of
like yes it's awesome there's AI it will
allow us to do all kinds of new things
and we're trying to sort out ways of how
we can develop our product to kind of
help their need which is mostly
designers being able to help design it
be more creative more of design that's
kind of the slogan which means we focus
on the creative parts and everything
which is inherently not creative like
creating variations of logos or whatever
you could call it automations we can
automate that but that makes it already
very great concepts right so certain
things of automation are inherently the
right thing to do right
inhumane work or mechanical work which
is easiest to automate this to
mechanical work so I would actually
argue that that's to work exactly which
should be automated right then you get
an all kinds of other questions about
labor and economy like what done
especially in global inequalities where
you know most people actually do have
you know make a living on a lot of this
kind of more sweatshop like or kind of
general labor like relations so that of
course another discussion their
disciplines doing a big corporate
settings but the other part is ok yes
great let's automate everything we could
fire everyone we can just only have the
senior you know the creative directors
and we get rid of out the universe so
that's the kind of two potentials and I
think the problem with those two choices
is really that there are no real clear
alternatives in the public discourse
about what is possible with AI so one of
the things we are trying to get to which
is really kind of trying to get to this
tournament idea of augmentation which I
will talk about in my talk as well which
is having AI just as a tool which we use
as humans and it's just like any other
to AI has always existed because always
it to just now that it has been
overhyped and it will always be you to
at least for for a very long foreseeable
time so it means what do we want to do
to it - and what do we want to make
possible it kind of connects my favorite
definition of I ions from the girl as a
buzz book basically I I is whatever
hasn't been done yet and the moment it's
being done you know we can do it we can
we solve chess yeah okay then it's
boring it's yesterday's news it's not
artificial intelligence anymore and I
think that's very healthy perspective on
that still lots of problems we have to
address but less magic and less so I
would probably solve this course is
super important telling alternative
stories and also holding firm to certain
if you had certain values or beliefs
stick to them as an engineer and find
ways to explain them in ways which
actually makes it valuable
I think there's anything like a lot of
value you can actually derive of being
different it doesn't necessarily you
don't have to fall
food with you know the standard so what
we're doing with creative area is like
we're exploring very different business
models which is difficult but yeah we
found some some ways of how we can make
it work so it's definitely possible but
just to touch on actually going back to
like the idea of you know robots taking
over jobs and things I mean clearly it's
already happening and it reminds me of a
very good quote from the original
cybernetics book from back in the 50s
which is basically when we have to
compete with slave labor which is what
the word he uses for robotic labor in
this we also then devalue ourselves to
the level of slaves and this is this
point where ok perhaps we as more
affluent societies we are like oh those
are menial tasks that we don't want to
do but does this mean globally that
everyone has equal access to these types
of industries and if we have robots in
one country competing with humans in
another country then we get into really
icky situations and I think that this is
a very good point and question and
something that we have to think about
also reminds me of another quote from
fight and mom I believe which is do I
care about how my research is used which
is another one of these like should we
have these licenses on research or like
how how come if I do research and
someone uses it for a very evil thing
who is culpable right but but would the
license prevent people from doing evil
things I mean I'm I'm a physicist and my
people have invented the nuclear bomb
and engine the people that invented it
wrote to the government to say like
don't use it on a civilian population
but the government still did so I you
know I really agree with you that like
we we should you know as a creator
and have some say about ìhow all the
things we create should be used in
practice it's hard to enforce I mean you
could think of a kind of defenses maybe
in north talk I text patents but in this
talk I'll be some patents so it was a
few weeks ago I saw the first archived
paper with a patent number in it already
so it means that even when research is
like pretty published there's already a
patent given out for it or overlooked
but you could argue that that's actually
the right thing to do if you want to
defend your inventions right
so these patents could just as well be
used for for for good use probably want
some action or some activity or AI
research community where people are
actually trying to influence the
policymakers on on these things so it's
similar to researchers for certain area
trying to influence you know distinct
some kind of like self policing and ng
happening so I think this is also a
positive trend is it on yeah so and yeah
this is the Manhattan Project conscience
science dilemma this is also valid for
computer scientists so I like that we
start the debate physicists are good at
this because young you know coming back
to the business so this is so far away
and so science is is that with those
submitter review in every cheap ad as
though this was not about AI it was
about machine learning which is
collecting data and so even in sync
single start up share and
a rating how you collect them the clean
data are normally first-rate and sent
them to the App Store and otherwise and
feedback is normal and but this is where
ethics already start so I would want to
get this away from rocket science back
to our all-day work within the CMO and
the CEOs dentists before board meeting
and want beautiful data are somehow
pressure then collecting privacy those
Apache locks and storing so it's not
only AI
and where does this start with data
engineering storing duplicate wrong
messy data I just sometimes wonder Oh
got it
I know how messy the data is it's not
the duped and some bugs are in if now
some data scientist comes and run some
analysis on this and finds a great thing
without knowing how how long the basis
should to also care about this maybe I
think that reaches to the point of
Francis right having a good code of
contact which they get is kind of high
aspects of how we think about that X and
then tries to bring them down to kind of
the company level and any kind of base
level of how do engineers then
operationalize these concepts in their
work and I think you make the larger
point right it's also about critical
engineers it's also about being good
being a good citizen in the end right
and it all connects to that and it's
like everybody everyday has to make many
many choices and you can decide to take
it over or to take public transport it's
just a decision you make and you make
that every day and you vote with your
wallet in the end of
so I got I got one more thought and now
we've had some conversation today or
heard some conversation about building
values or ethical values moral into into
nai now suppose it works this is more
like a queue for a science fiction
writer at the moment but suppose it
works and the AI actually becomes better
at than we are because the AI will not
throw their ethical values out of the in
window when it gets very hungry for
instance or someone offers it a lot of
money what what's going to happen I
don't I have no not the slightest clue
but I'm very interested so like we'll be
picky modest quite a lot and there are
multiple answers one is that what we
would like to do is to actually build a
human level AI and like Darren can like
freeze it for a while on this level then
use it to find a way how to merge with
this AI like whatever that means in like
some like nano machines or whatever or
just like some communication so merge we
desire and then continue improving
together vdj as one system and just like
today we all are some kind of cyborgs
see like we are using all the technology
you know that we're not here thousand
years ago and we are okay with it and
and then the next part of the of the
answer would be our value system would
be still evolving just like it has been
evolving for past thousand four hundred
years even like all this kind of like
beaming rights or slavery and I don't
know what other things has changed you
know during in a value system during the
time but these things change and I think
they will change and so basically if we
freeze at the value system of the AI
from for forever and we also like these
are the three of similar laws or
something like this and they can never
change like never ever chain
then actually you'd put this AI or us
you know dislike future society in a
huge disadvantage because the situation
in coming hundreds of years or centuries
or millennia may be different than
notice today like I think there are
stuff with people or dislike this new
kind of species will be solving will be
quite different from what we are solving
right now like for example right now we
have human rights we have some like like
assets for example and if the AI can
clone itself you know like then who
actually owns the assets in like every
clone it gets divided or not alike it's
really complicated so I think even these
things you'll have to change or I think
even our our view on death and things
will change and I have some ideas about
this but maybe they're a little bit not
crazy but I think like they they are not
as actual to their you know so it's
really not that relevant so to put this
together I think the value system will
be changing evolving in few centuries it
will be quite different than what we
have today but if we get there
continuously gradually like from one
change to another another another it
will not feel alien to us you know just
imagine that for example if some romance
would wake up today and they will come
here and they will be like okay so where
you have your slides you know and and
all the other things and they'll be like
why you change your value system like
you're so weird and but if they actually
gradually went through the history like
like people it would feel very natural
to them and yeah so that's that's cancer
was I think rather span so lost
transversal is the code of conduct it's
put Shopify's that online you do you
have to the code of conduct
do you have it published online would it
be a good start of having a blog post on
that either blog post or my sides will
be online here and okay
our copies and the size because perhaps
it would be easy to just start a code of
conduct initiative where kind of data
science companies could just adopt them
and change them and do with the model
one to make some kind of public justice
terror kind of you know code of conduct
for for conferences and things like that
it would be nice
[Applause]